the new gun law is not an inspiring
example of bipartisan cooperation to
protect public safety prohibited persons
who are legally disqualified from owning
firearms include millions of americans
with no history of violence such as
cannabis consumers former psychiatric
patients who have never been deemed a
threat to others and people convicted of
drug crimes or other non-violent
felonies thanks to this law a cannabis
consumer could go to prison for up to 15
years if he obtains a gun even if he
lives in a state that has legalized
marijuana that trafficking and firearms
penalty also applies to people who have
lost the right to own guns under state
law even when they are not disqualified
under federal law these new penalties
will disproportionately harm
african-americans even the american
civil liberties union which thinks the
right to keep and bear arms is a figment
of the supreme court's imagination
recognizes that the categories of people
that federal law currently prohibits
from possessing or purchasing a gun are
overbroad and not reasonably related to
the state's interest in public safety
you